As we've already talked about, there are a number
of different people being sued by Dominion voting
systems for the allegedly libelous claims that
have been made by people like Rudy Giuliani and
Trump's other lawyer, Sydney Powell, although
it went back and forth as to whether she really
is his lawyer or not. And now she is coming up
with what I call the Tucker Carlson, Alex Jones,
Fox News Defense, which is you can't sue me
over the things I said about you, Dominion,
because nobody in their right mind would believe
that I was saying things that are actually to be
believed. This is actually the defense that she's
putting out there. A Forbes has a very interesting
report which
explains that former Trump lawyer and conspiracy
theorist Sidney Powell moved to dismiss a lawsuit
filed against her by Dominion voting systems,
arguing that her earlier claims that Dominion was
involved in an orchestrated voter fraud effort
were so outrageous that, quote, reasonable
people would not accept such statements as facts.
We experienced this with Tucker Carlson.
When Tucker was recently sued, Fox News
lawyers actually argued in court. People should
understand, viewers should know that Tucker
isn't reporting facts, he's using hyperbole and
doing like an entertainment show, so you can't
hold them accountable for the things that he
says, which is a fascinating and, of course,
true defense, but not at all how Fox News wants
to be understood. They want to be understood as
reporting facts when it's when it's
convenient, when
the legal rubber hits the road, all of a sudden
these shows are entertainment. This is hyperbole.
This is a performance. Alex Jones, his lawyers
using the defense in one of the many lawsuits
that Alex Jones, the conspiracy theorist, faced,
saying Jones is playing a character on his show.
The things he are saying are more like an
actor reading lines. You wouldn't charge an
actor with sexual assault because in character
they admit to a sexual assault. It's the same
essential that they didn't use that example.
But that's essentially what they're saying.
It's the same with Alex Jones and Sidney Powles
lawyers. Yes, lawyers need lawyers that if Magga
stands for anything, it's making attorneys
get attorneys. Sidney Powells lawyers argued
that her claims about Dominion
were, quote,
opinions and legal theories and not statements
meant for the public to literally believe
and that that she simply shouldn't be held
legally liable in this way. Now, what's completely
pathetic and transparent about this is
that she was saying these things as a
lawyer who was
actually filing motions. Now, as we know,
the Trump campaign and administration went back
and forth about whether Sidney Powell actually
represented them. Trump did tweet multiple times,
listing Sidney Powell as someone who was leading
the effort to overturn the election that Trump
claimed was stolen from him after she went cuckoo
for Cocoa Puffs during some press
briefing
meant to explain their legal strategy. The
Trump campaign or the Trump White House said
she has nothing to do with us. But then she was
back at the White House meeting with Trump and
talking about I don't remember she was talking
about martial law or seizing voting machines or
whatever the case was. But the bottom line is that
lawyers are saying this was just these were just,
you know, ideas. They weren't meant to be
taken as fact. And she doesn't even really
have enough connection to this area of law and
she shouldn't be held accountable. So the lessons
here are, number
one,
they are admitting she's a charlatan. The legal
defense is based on nobody should have believed
the things that she was saying. And number two,
this applies to so much of right wing media.
You know, when when they get in trouble for making
completely dangerous anti medical anti science
based statements about coronavirus and the rubber
meets the road legally, so to speak, they say, oh,
yeah, maybe we weren't giving medical advice.
This was just like these were just ideas and
nobody should take them seriously. Everybody
should be talking to their doctor or whatever
the case may be. And in fact, there are some right
wing channels we were watching a live stream of
I think it was
on Rightside Broadcasting when during CPAC,
I think it was Mike Lyndell or someone else
started making bogus claims about coronavirus
and the election results. They cut away and read
a statement which was about, you know, everybody
said we are not endorsing any of these claims.
Everybody should check with their own doctors
or whatever the case may be. So they all sort of
know that this is just something they're doing for
ratings and to create clicks and interest.
But they will
immediately abandon these positions as soon as it
gets legally hot as it is getting now for Sydney
Powell. And we'll just follow and see ultimately
what happens with this lawsuit against her. But
she's going for the No. One could possibly have
believed the things I was saying anyway. Defense.